we have a very special edition of the
news today i am freaking out because our
guest he is a viral phenomenon
he has been taking the internet by storm
with his love of corn and do we love
i really him to read
with millions upon millions of views
your video has gone all over the world
to wreak your hand
i mean
why do you think everybody loves you so
much
mostly because
like the code bands and my level cone
but also because some teenagers were
saying i looked adorable yeah well
yeah well i have to tell you every age
of every person on this planet thinks
you're adorable and wonderful and you've
just
made people so happy and i if i had to
guess what people love about you so much
as
how happy and kind and sweet you are and
we all need that in the world right now
always yes
we certainly do
and your love of corn really popped
everybody's so impressed we know we know
you love corn what are some other things
that you love
well i also like i love watermelon
apples broccoli soccer and also school
and reading books to my baby sister
zahava
do you like reading books to your baby
sister my name's lava she was born june
15th
what a good brother you are
oh my goodness
well i know that you love corn and so we
thought today for our news since it's
all about you tariq i mean it's all
about you we thought we would do
some fantastic food
um in food news court edition
[Applause]
first up it's corn soda i didn't even
know this existed have you heard of this
before uh yeah i saw it one day i saw it
in the cone palace
in the corn palace what's the corn
palace it's a pet it's a it's a it's
like it's a castle bit of cone wow
that's not eatable not you can't eat it
not eatable do you think it's gonna
taste good
before we taste i would like to make a
toast
[Applause]
oh
wow
um
what do you think
all right next up maybe this will be a
little bit better it's
dessert corn i hope you heard about this
one just bang it oh my sprinkles are
going everywhere sorry this has nutella
and sprinkles on corn you think this is
going to be good yep yep all right you
want to try it yes okay
i'm trying the sprinkles first okay
sprinkles first
oh my god
i know you know what
i was not looking forward to it and it's
actually kind of good
do i have a little
drink what did i have to say
this is the most best cone i've ever had
in my life
[Applause]
by the way here's a baby corn oh oh you
ever had baby corn
you want to try it sure
did you ever see the movie big with tom
hanks
i don't remember i don't even get what
big means well there's a famous scene in
it where he takes the baby corn and he
goes
okay outside the baby
baby corn here let me get you a perfect
one oh my god tell me what you think
it doesn't exactly taste like corn does
it it ca yeah it says like rain water
but
rain rainforest
all right you want to try it i'll try it
with you
dude like tom hanks from big
it's about
it tastes like rain water and tasted
like a carrot
like rain water and carrots all right
baby corn industry tariq has spoken yeah
all right well i would love for you to
try something this is a corn product
that actually isn't corn at all it's one
of my favorites this is
corn with a q
but it's pronounced corn and i'm
actually the chief mom officer of this
company so if you don't mind will you
try one of these and
yeah
okay hmm
[Applause]
we're so glad that you like it tariq
because corn
this wonderful company is giving you a
year's free supply of corn products
you can have it any time that you want
thank you everyone
[Applause]
[Music]
thank you thank you thank you i'm so
glad that you like it and we have
another surprise for you actually um we
know you love to play and use your
imagination so our friends at the iconic
famous toy store where ironically the
movie big
has a famous scene in it it's ethio
schwartz and they are celebrating their
160th anniversary and they are going to
give you a five thousand dollar shopping
spree
[Applause]
oh my god
[Music]